Azerbaiyán es ese país que no sabías ni
que existía hasta que un día viste el festival
de Eurovisión.
Sin embargo, es un país con mucho que ofrecer
al mundo.
Sí, hablamos otra vez de gas natural.
Pero, creedme, hay mucho más.
Vito Corleone decía que “la familia es
muy importante” y, lo cierto es que en Azerbaiyán
han seguido su consejo.
La familia ALIYEV lo es todo en este país.
Controlan la política y la economía con
mano de hierro.
Sin embargo, a la hora de negociar, no colocan
cabezas de caballo sino… ¡Caviar!
Sí, habéis oído bien.
Los Aliyev pueden ser corruptos y represores
con sus propios ciudadanos, pero en cuanto
llega alguien del extranjero, saben tratarle
como a una rockstar.
Si de algo saben en este país, es de diplomacia.
Y eso explica que, aunque hagan frontera con
Irán, Azerbaiyan está en el Consejo de Europa,
participa en Eurovisión y juega en la Eurocopa.
Y diréis ¿Pero qué tiene Azerbaiyán que
les hace tan atractivos?
Pues… aparte del caviar, el mar Caspio tiene
otras cosas muy interesantes.
Tenemos enormes reservas de petróleo y, por
supuesto, gas natural.
¿Y recordáis quién necesita diversificar
sus proveedores de Gas Natural?
¡Exacto!
La Unión Europea.
Si habéis visto los vídeos anteriores de
esta serie, ya sabéis que Alemania, Finlandia
y todo el Este de Europa depende muchísimo
del gas ruso.
Así que, por muy corruptos y represores que
sean los Aliyev, a Bruselas no le queda más
remedio que hacer negocios con ellos.
¡Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando!
¡Seguro que a Putin no le hace ninguna gracia!
A fin de cuentas, a Rusia le interesa que
Europa depende de su gas.
Es decir, que eso de buscar otros proveedores
son malas noticias para el Kremlin ¿Verdad?
¡Pues nada de eso!
Como buenos maestros de la diplomacia, los
Aliyev han sido capaces de caerle bien a todo
el mundo.
Incluido a Putin.
Así que ahora la pregunta es ¿Qué importancia
tiene el régimen de Bakú para los planes
del Kremlin?
Hoy vamos a responder a esta preguntas, y
lo vamos a hacer junto a nuestro buen amigo…
ALEJANDRO, nada más y nada menos que el autor
de Hipótesis de Poder.
“Hola Fonseca y un abrazo a todos los suscriptores
de VisualPolitik.
Como bien dices, los Aliyev son unos auténticos
maestros de la diplomacia.
Pero ¿Cómo han conseguido asociarse con
Putin y, a la vez, con la Unión Europa?
¿Qué tiene que ver Ucrania con todo esto?
Pues ahora sí, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
LA DIPLOMACIA DEL CAVIAR
Mayo de 2014.
El uruguayo Diego Godín acaba de marcar el
gol que hace campeón de la Liga Española
de fútbol al Atlético de Madrid.
Millones de espectadores en todo el mundo
ven en su camiseta Azerbaiyan, Land of fire.
Y así fue entre el año 2012 y el año 2015.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué un país como
Azerbaiyan se gasta 24 millones de euros en
publicidad?
En fin ¿Conocéis a mucha gente que se haya
ido de turismo a este país?
Obviamente, la respuesta no tiene nada que
ver con el turismo.
Como sabéis, las guerras del gas entre Rusia
y Ucrania dejaron a muchos países europeos
sin calefacción en el año 2009.
En ese momento, la Unión Europea se puso
a buscar otras alternativas al gas ruso.
¿Y qué pasaba mientras en Azerbaiyan?
Pues que, en el año 2006, entraba en operaciones
el megayacimiento gasista de SHAH DENIZ, con
reservas suficientes como para poder reducir
la dependencia rusa en casi un 10%.
Es decir, que Europa estaba como loca buscando
proveedores y Azerbaiyán estaba buscando
compradores.
El amor estaba en el aire.
Pero, como sabéis, en el juego del amor,
a veces necesitamos un pequeño chispazo de
pasión.
Y ahí es donde entra la llamada Diplomacia
del Caviar.
Veréis, hacer tratos con una dictadura no
es agradable.
Pero en Bakú, la capital de Azerbaiyan, tienen
dinero para eso y más.
¿Que nadie quiere organizar los primeros
Juegos Europeos, una especie de juegos olímpicos
pero solo para Europa sin sentido económico?
Pues ahí está Azerbaiyán poniendo sus petrodólares.
¿Que Valencia, epicentro de los casos de
corrupción de España, deja de organizar
el gran premio de Europa de Fórmula 1?
Pues ahí está Azerbaiyán con sus petrodólares
¿Qué hacen falta patrocinadores para la
Eurocopa?
Pues ahí está Azerbaiyán con sus petrodólares.
Da igual que sea la marca de Azerbaiyán “Land
of Fire” o, simplemente, la marca de SOCAR,
que es la empresa petrolera de este país,
lo cierto es que el dinero y el caviar de
los Aliyev están en todas partes.
Y eso explica noticias como esta.
Euro 2020: prepárate para partidos desde
Bilbao a Bakú
Efectivamente, la próxima Eurocopa se disputará
en 11 países europeos y Azerbaiyán ha sido
uno de los países elegidos por delante de
otros con mayor tradición futbolística como
Bulgaria o Suecia.
Y con este tipo de eventos, Azerbaiyan ha
conseguido lavar su imagen y comprar voluntades.
Gracias a esto es como nadie pone la más
mínima pega para construir todos los gasoductos
necesarios.
En primer lugar está el Gasoducto del Cáucaso
Sur, una tubería para llevar el gas desde
el yacimiento del mar Caspio a territorio
turco a través de Georgia.
Funciona desde 2006.
No penséis que estaba borracho el que trazó
el gasoducto: Armenia y Azerbaiyán se llevan
peor que Rusia y Ucrania, así que mejor dar
un rodeo por Georgia.
Pero también hay un segundo gasoducto, el
TANAP, que llega hasta Grecia, y que se ha
inaugurado este año.
Pero el proyecto final es el llamado TAP,
que llegaría hasta Italia.
Y os preguntaréis… ¿Qué piensa Putin
de esto?
Pues… en principio, no le hizo la más mínima
gracia.
Y, en un principio, intentó evitar que el
gas de Azerbaiyan llegara a Italia por todos
los medios ¿Recordáis que el hombre de Putin
en Berlin es el ex canciller Gerhard Schroeder?
Pues el hombre de Putin en Roma es nada menos
que Beppe Grillo, del movimiento Cinco Estrellas.
El Gobierno de Estados Unidos advierte a Italia:
"Tengan cuidado.
Hay relación entre Rusia y el Movimiento
Cinco Estrellas"
Y eso explica que Beppe Grillo soltara declaraciones
como esta.
“Si vienen a hacer el oleoducto en Puglia
desde cualquier lugar, incluso con el Ejército,
pondremos a nuestro ejército”
Sin embargo… vamos a pausarlo justo aquí.
Estas declaraciones son del año 2014.
Sin embargo, ahora estamos en 2018.
Cuatro años dan para mucho.
Así que vamos a echar un poco adelante en
el tiempo.
TODO QUEDA EN CASA
Toda dinastía tiene a su patriarca.
Y la historia de Heydar Aliyev impresiona.
Empezó siendo un espía de la KGB y estuvo
25 años jugando a ser el James Bond de Bakú.
En 1969 Breznev le nombró líder de la república
soviética de Azerbaiyán.
En los años 80 ascendió al Politburó del
Kremlin hasta que chocó con Gorbachov.
En 1991 Azerbaiyán logró su independencia
y en 2 años Heydar Aliyev ya se había convertido
en su presidente con un… estad atentos,
98,8% de los votos.
Heydar era un hombre pragmático.
En menos de un año había firmado un alto
el fuego con Armenia y lo que se conoce como
el Contrato del Siglo: la británica BP, las
americanas Exxon, Chevron, la noruega Statoil…
nadie se quiso perder la posibilidad de explotar
el crudo del mar Caspio.
Azerbaiyán se reservaba el 80% de los beneficios.
De hecho, ¿os acordáis de cuál es la primera
imagen de James Bond en Azerbaiyán en El
mundo nunca es suficiente?: conducir un coche
entre pozos petrolíferos.
Así que la economía de Azerbaiiyán va como
un tiro: petróleo, gas y caviar.
El país crece.
Y la corrupción también.
Todo queda en familia.
Ya lo decía Vito Corleone: Un hombre que
no pasa tiempo con su familia no puede ser
un hombre.
Así que a la muerte del patriarca Heydar
en 2003, todo estaba atado y bien atado para
que su hijo Ilham fuera el heredero.
Ganó las elecciones con un 75% de los votos.
Pero en dictaduras así, con el tiempo hemos
aprendido que el porcentaje es lo de menos.
Azerbaiyán dio a conocer los resultados de
las elecciones antes de que la votación hubiera
comenzado.
Ilham Aliyev no se corta un pelo.
Eliminó de la Constitución el límite de
mandatos presidenciales.
Ha colocado a su mujer de vicepresidenta,
cargo creado para ella.
Y también ha eliminado la edad mínima de
35 años de los candidatos a ocupar la Presidencia.
Su hijo varón aún tiene 21 años y nunca
se sabe.
Por supuesto, todo el que se mueve contra
los Aliyev acaba entre rejas.
Los Aliyev mientras tanto se han hecho millonarios
¿Os acordáis de los papeles de Panamá?
Pues sí, parece que con la ayuda del despacho
Mossack Fonseca, los Aliyev montaron un auténtico
imperio.
Y no, por si alguien se lo preguntaba, Mossack
Fonseca no tiene nada que ver con mi familia.
El caso es que… ¿Qué haces cuando tienes
dinero?
Pues… lo usas para hacer amigos.
Investigación sobre corrupción en el Consejo
de Europa sobre Azerbaiyán
Pero lo sé… todavía no hemos contestado
a la pregunta ¿Qué han hecho en Azerbaiyan
para llevarse bien con Putin?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
REALISMO POLÍTICO
Michael Corleone lo sabía: Ten cerca a tus
amigos, pero más cerca a tus enemigos.
Y, si recordáis, Vladimir Putin tiene dos
objetivos: vender gas a Europa y aislar económicamente
a Ucrania.
Las guerras del gas impulsaron el gasoducto
Nord Stream 1 y 2, que manda el gas ruso hasta
Alemania por el Báltico.
Pero claro, eso no es suficiente.
Necesitan nuevas tuberías para terminar de
aislar a Ucrania.
Sin embargo, no creáis que construir tuberías
en Europa es tan fácil.
Mirad esta noticia:
Bulgaria suspende el proyecto de gasoducto
South Stream
A diferencia de Azerbaiyan, a Putin no se
le da muy bien la diplomacia.
La invasión de Crimea provocó una serie
de sanciones económica a Rusia y se llevó
por delante este gasoducto que habían propuesto
desde el Kremlin.
Así que Putin se dio cuenta de que tenía
que buscarse una estrategia política mejor.
Y pensándolo mejor, el Southern Gas Corridor
le viene muy bien.
Si Europa está invirtiendo en el sur para
recibir gas de Azerbaiyán… les puede llevar
el gas hasta ahí.
Y ese es el objetivo del gasoducto que Rusia
acaba de construir bajo el mar Negro: el TurkStream.
Se trata de una tubería enorme, que no sólo
sirve para suministrar gas a Turquía, sino
a toda Europa.
En otras palabras, la jugada de Rusia es la
siguiente.
Ellos llevan el gas a Turquía.
Y de ahí, se podría enganchar al TAP que
llega hasta Italia.
Es decir, que esa tubería que se había diseñado
para gas de Azerbaiyán, ahora llevará también
gas ruso.
En otras palabras, que Aliyev ya no es una
amenaza para Putin, sino una oportunidad.
Las cosas han cambiado en Rusia.
Y, por supuesto, también en Italia ¿Recordáis
que el Movimiento 5 estrellas estaba totalmente
en contra del TAP en el año 2014?
Pues ahora, que están en el gobierno, la
postura ha cambiado.
Di Maio: “El TAP no es estratégico, pero
está blindado”
Y mientras tanto, hay otros dos líderes que
se han vuelto muy, pero que muy amigos.
Todos salen ganando.
La Unión Europea diversifica.
Azerbaiyán se forra.
Rusia encuentra otra vía para vender su gas
en Europa y Ucrania… todos ganan menos Ucrania,
que tiene un futuro muy negro.
Pero ahora las preguntas son para vosotros.
¿Creéis que Putin conseguirá burlarse de
Europa y circulará el gas ruso por el TAP?
¿Hasta cuándo pensáis que los Aliyev podrán
manejar Azerbaiyán como si fuera la empresa
familiar?
¿Cómo creéis que acabará todo esto para
Ucrania?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y, por supuesto, no olvidéis visitar el canal
Hipótesis de Poder, donde también se habla
de geopolítica y relaciones internacionales.
Si queréis pasaros por mi canal, hemos hecho
un vídeo con VIsualPolitik donde hablamos
de la batalla por el control del Ártico.
Y como siempre, si os ha gustado este vídeo,
suscribíos a VisualPolitik y dadle a la campanita
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.